you do going into it was going to be a
lot of work and we often hear we often
hear that crowdfunding is so much work
it's it's not often broken down in terms
of what that work is so like what is the
kind of work that you're doing what is
it entail what is it that just has you
you know this word you're like every
second of the day you're trying to raise
this money what is this we can you break
it down for us yeah I think it's a lot
of reaching out to you know reaching out
to people we know reaching out to our
network to friends to try to find places
find places where it can connect or what
we're doing will resonate with someone
and we weren't sure I think when we
launched we weren't sure what that was
going to be if it was going to be you
know the fact that our webseries going
to feature it goes going to be the
sci-fi aspect if it was going to be um
you know one of the things that we're
doing is we have to Latino leads but
it's not their non stereotypical roles
it's Universal they just so happen to be
Latino which is something that you don't
see that often and we found that that
resonated but that wasn't really our
focus when we started and I think how do
we known where to focus rather than just
kind of throwing it off in all these
different directions I think that would
have helped us narrow their our focus um
sooner because the other ones just kind
of necessarily fall on deaf ears but it
wasn't enough to um kind of generate
momentum going forward and that was the
other does the other thing that we found
I think is that um you know when we're
sending emails off and were you know
letting people know and then tweeting
about it and on Facebook about it um
constantly we start to see something
build but the second we stop everything
else stops and when you start again you
still have to have to start on a zero
all over again and you just you have if
you want to build the momentum you have
to keep it going otherwise it drops in
and you have to start from the same
point every time every time I mean
recently I mean our recently like in the
in the last couple days we've sort of
been doubling all of those efforts so I
mean we have been contacting you know
different blogs and
and that kind of thing but I'm even that
and of itself is like figuring out how
to do that takes up time too because
it's like okay well this is a blog I
want to contact and like you have an
email but that doesn't mean anything if
you don't know them if you've never
spoken to them or even reach out to them
before and so I mean for me I got lucky
with one of them were you know I just
started like tweeting about that her a
little bit until they cut did me I was
like okay well that worked so like
making those kind of discoveries as
you're going like oh that's how you
reach out to them but I mean when all
you have is the Kickstarter page it's
like you know is that going to be enough
to contact somebody and say hey we have
this cool project or is that just gonna
be like yeah I get like a hundred of
these a day so kind of finding that
balance of like which one is going to
respond and then actually executing them
figuring out how to reach up to them in
the way that they're going to you know
want to respond husband has been really
challenging as well and not getting
discouraged when you don't hear back to
I think it's really important because
like she said you know there are places
that get 100's and you know random
emails here and there I mean I'm sure
you know film courage got a bunch of
random help me out of my campaign kind
of thing and you know we haven't
necessarily a built up a lot of
relationships with you know a lot of
places that can help us get the word out
with some but you know what the ones we
have and how do we approach them and if
they don't if they don't get back in
touch with us you know that that makes
sense given what we know um and to not
get discouraged about that and say oh
that means that they don't believe in us
because it just means you know they have
a very large inbox with me new emails
and you know we might get lucky we might
not
you